madame monsieur bonsoir l'événement du
jour n'est ni un fait divers
ni politique ni sportif il est
artistique yves saint laurent est un
grand couturier
ça c'est une évidence il est également
un industriel qui exportent toute une
gamme de produits made in france dans le
monde entier il est l'un des quelques
noms français connus internationalement
il n'y en a pas beaucoup mais il a su
rester un créateur et la collection
automne-hiver 88 qu'il a présenté
aujourd'hui même a époustouflé
véritablement les spectateurs et pour la
première fois depuis longtemps
eh bien il ça laurent qui n'est pas un
homme à rechercher les caméras parle de
son art et de sa manière de créer
yauba grégoire
couleurs d'été pour jour d'hiver aux et
fuchsia mélange de couleurs osées dix
ans laurent devenu désormais un
classique
fourreau en crêpe de soie ou en satin
draper qui rappelle la grande période
des stars 2
et
la wi lan dernier l'automne ce sont les
feuilles mortes ici brodé en relief
l'automne c'est la période des vendanges
les raisins également broderie tombent
en grappes sur les épaules le couturier
commandes et françois lesage et exécute
6 millions de points de broderie pour 20
modèles 6000 heures de travail
les dernières robes ont été livrés
quelques heures avant le défilé
parce qu'il ya des racines très
profondes dans cette collection
qui vit ronde entre
et combien de temps mettez vous à créer
quelques semaines et là je souffre
terriblement parce que c'est pas
j'hésite je cherche et puis tout d'un
coup ça arrive comme un miracle et puis
voilà
en trois semaines on fait ça on a
l'impression vous allez jamais arrêté de
de faire des merveilles
oui j'étais un privilège qui m'a été
donné à ma naissance je ne sais pas je
ne comprends pas mais ça se réalise
chaque fois